El ingreso por innovación es la ganancia que genera
los nuevos productos y servicios vendidos en los últimos 3 años,
es decir, no les preguntamos cuántas ideas creativas tenían,
sino más bien si dichas ideas se traducían en productos y servicios
que hacían a la empresa más próspera hoy y mañana.
Para medir la diversidad evaluamos seis distintos factores:
entre ellos, el país de origen, la edad y el género.
Al prepararnos para realizar la encuesta en el campo,
nos sentamos con mi equipo a discutir los resultados que esperábamos.
A decir verdad, no éramos muy optimistas.
El miembro más escéptico del equipo creía o veía una gran posibilidad
de no lograr nada con esto.
La mayor parte tenía un enfoque prudente,
y al final adoptamos un nuevo enfoque "solo si",
es decir, puede que encontremos un vínculo
entre la innovación y la diversidad
pero no de manera consistente...
más bien, "solo si" se cumplen ciertos criterios
como por ejemplo, un estilo de liderazgo lo suficientemente abierto
que permita a la gente hablar con libertad y poder contribuir.
Dos meses después llegó la información
y los resultados convencieron al más incrédulo del grupo.
La respuesta era un sí rotundo
sin 'quizás' ni 'peros'.
Los datos obtenidos mostraron
que las empresas más heterogéneas son simplemente, las más innovadoras.
Ahora, hagámonos la pregunta: ¿Qué fue primero, el huevo o la gallina?
o sea, ¿las empresas realmente son más innovadoras
por tener una directiva más diversa,
o lo opuesto?
¿Cómo funciona esto?
Ahora bien, no sabemos qué tanto es correlación y qué tanto causalidad,
pero lo que si sabemos con certeza es que,
en nuestra muestra, las empresas más heterogéneas
son más innovadoras,
y las empresas más innovadoras
tienen directivas más heterogéneas, también.
Es razonable creer que funciona en ambas direcciones:
la diversidad conduce a la innovación y viceversa.
Cuando se publicaron los resultados,
nos vimos sorprendidos por las reacciones que tuvieron los medios.
Obtuvimos mucha atención.
Pasó de ser algo bastante fáctico,
tal como "más mujeres, mayor innovación"
a algo más exagerado
(Risas)
como esto:
"Las amas de casa cuestan billones",
y mi favorita:
"Amas de casa matan la innovación".
Bueno, creo que no es tan mala la publicidad, ¿no creen?
(Risas)
Luego de esa cobertura mediática,
comenzamos a recibir llamadas de directores ejecutivos
que querían comprender mejor,
especialmente, adivinen sobre la diversidad de género.
Suelo hacer esta pregunta para abrir los debates:
"¿Qué opinas de la situación actual de tu empresa?"
Una respuesta frecuente es:
"Bueno, aún no hemos logrado nada pero ahí la llevamos".
Por ejemplo, un director me dijo:
"No estamos tan mal,
uno de los miembros de la junta directiva es mujer".
(Risas)
Y se ríen...
(Aplausos)
Se ríen, no obstante, él tiene algo de qué sentirse orgulloso,
porque en Alemania,
si tienes una empresa
y uno de los miembros de la junta es mujer,
eres parte de un grupo selecto de 30
de las 100 empresas públicas más grandes.
En las 70 empresas restantes, el consejo directivo se conforma solo por hombres
Y ni siquiera una de esas 100 empresas más cotizadas
tiene, actualmente una mujer como directora ejecutiva.
Sin embargo, esto se debe de considerar:
las pocas mujeres que conforman la mesa directiva,
no harán ninguna diferencia.
Los resultados muestran que para que la diversidad de género
tenga un impacto en la innovación,
se requiere que más de 20 % de los cargos directivos sean ocupados por mujeres.
Echemos un vistazo a los números.
Como ven, dividimos la muestra en tres grupos,
y los resultados fueron muy sorprendentes.
solo en el grupo donde hay más del 20 % de mujeres en cargos directivos,
solo entonces se observa un claro incremento en los ingresos por innovación
por encima del promedio.
La experiencia y los resultados muestran que se requiere una masa crítica
para hacer mover las cosas,
y empresas como Alibaba, JP Morgan o Apple ya han alcanzado estos niveles.
Otra respuesta frecuente también era:
"El tiempo solucionará esto".
Entiendo perfectamente este punto de vista,
puesto que yo también creía eso.
Ahora, volvamos a analizar esto y revisemos los números,
tomando a Alemania por ejemplo.
Permítanme comenzar con las buenas noticias.
El número de mujeres que se gradúa de la universidad
y que cuenta con al menos diez años de experiencia profesional,
ha incrementado bastante en los últimos 20 años,
lo que significa que el grupo de posibles candidatos mujeres
ha aumentado con el paso del tiempo
lo cual es grandioso.
Ahora bien, según mi antigua teoría,
la proporción de mujeres directivas debió
aumentar de forma paralela, ¿no?
Veamos qué fue lo que pasó realmente.
Ni siquiera estamos cerca.
Lo cual quiere decir que estaba muy equivocada,
es decir, que mi generación
y la suya,
la generación femenina más preparada de todos los tiempos,
no lo hemos logrado.
No hemos logrado ganar cargos directivos de manera significativa.
La preparación no se tradujo en liderazgo.
Me dolió darme cuenta de eso
y me hizo pensar que,
si queremos cambiar la situación,
debemos comprometernos y hacer las cosas mejor.
Ahora bien, ¿qué se debe hacer?
Superar el 20 % de mujeres en cargos directivos
parece una tarea que desalienta a muchas,
lo cual es entendible debido a los antecedentes.
No obstante, es factible,
y hay muchas empresas actuales que están progresando
y lo están haciendo exitosamente.
Como ejemplo, tomemos a la empresa software SAP.
En el 2011, el 19% de
mujeres ocupaban cargos directivos,
sin embargo, decidieron mejorar
e hicieron lo que se hace en cualquier otra área de negocios
donde se quiere mejorar
Se establecieron como meta alcanzar el 25 % para el 2017,
la cual ya lograron este año.
Tales metas los volvía más creativos en la formación de directivos
y en el acceso a nuevas fuentes de reclutamiento.
Su nueva meta para el 2022 es que el 30 % de cargos directivos los ocupen mujeres.
La experiencia muestra que se puede lograr,
y al final,
todo depende de dos decisiones que muchos de nosotros
tomamos cada día en cada empresa:
a quién contrato, y a quién capacito y promuevo.
No tengo nada contra los programas para las mujeres,
redes de contacto, tutorías y capacitaciones.
Todas son buenas.
Sin embargo, estas son las dos decisiones
que al final envían la señal de cambio más poderosa
en cualquier empresa.
Ahora bien, nunca dije que era una defensora de la diversidad.
Soy una asesora financiera.
No obstante, mi objetivo actual es cambiar la cara del liderazgo:
hacerlo más diverso...
y no para que los directores marquen una casilla
y sientan que han cumplido con un requisito
o que han sido políticamente correctos.
Sino para que entiendan
que la diversidad hace a su empresa
más innovadora y más exitosa.
Que al aceptar la diversificación y la pluralidad de talentos,
ofrecemos a todos una verdadera oportunidad.
Gracias. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)